fundamental question
and we've been talking about this in
different forms and different contexts
over the past couple of days but here's
the reality peter
football teams every year engage in a
broad comprehensive look at the roster
and they decide where they can upgrade
where they should upgrade where they
have an opportunity to upgrade
do the 49ers given that contract
structure that gives them until april 1
to make a decision about jimmy garoppolo
do they owe it to the organization to at
least engage in the analysis as to
whether or not there is a potential
upgrade out there over jimmy garoppolo
dispassionate objective name off the
back of the jersey forget what you've
paid him look at the situation look at
the options should they engage in that
exercise
should they
maybe will they
i think almost absolutely not and i'll
tell you why
because
you know last year when jimmy garoppolo
was hurt
kyle shanahan asked his dad mike
shanahan the two-time super bowl winning
coach and quarterback whisper
hey would you come to santa clara
and would you uh basically teach
our offense
to jimmy garoppolo from the ground up
now he's got eight or nine weeks of
nothing other than rehab
i want him to learn everything about
this offense from the ground up
and mike shanahan came he worked with
him four or five days a week five hours
a day and he gave him homework he said
you got to go home and do this so
at the end of that period the 49ers had
uh a guy who thought exactly like kyle
shanahan and who knew the offense
exactly like kyle shanahan maybe not you
know every little
detour on the road but he knew
everything about this offense now
and this was his first year his first
full season
in the nfl
he went to new orleans and put up 48
points he had some blips on his radar
the super bowl he had some blips yep the
home game against seattle on monday
night an inglorious game by garoppolo
but he had enough positive things that
happened this year that i firmly believe
that the 49ers are all in on garoppolo
and will not look elsewhere yeah i i'm
with you too peter you know mike i mean
to your to what you're saying you know i
do think kyle
will get into the analysis of upgrading
everybody i think he's going to evaluate
garoppolo hard but i think it's also one
of those things where
yeah he'll evaluate it hard but the
analysis is going to have to be totally
like a disaster for him to go okay maybe
we should look about you know signing a
free agent quarterback or making a move
to change a quarterback and i just don't
think we're going to get there you know
yeah you know peter mentioned it the
saints game the seahawks game week 17.
you know it was a lot of good quality
play the grass isn't always green who
are you going to bring in that's
necessarily definitely better right this
was a super bowl team it is his first
year as a starter okay and we saw when
shanahan was in atlanta matt ryan
exploded his second full year in that
offense so i i think this is a team
that's still in their super bowl window
and i don't know why you would upset
that i know we want to blame jimmy
garoppolo i get it you know and it's
easy to blame them too because we saw
the guy on the other side of the field
make all the big plays when it mattered
well hey just to like
nobody is that guy nobody number 15 is
the guy there's just nobody he has a
chance to be the greatest player we've
ever seen in football he has that type
of talent so as i sit here and do this
you know yeah i think they're fine with
jimmy garoppolo i'm more concerned about
their defense letting up 21 points in
the last six minutes of a game when
their team was built around defense and
five first rounders on their d-line to
me if we're going to blame anybody that
is what annoys me more about the game
than anything else
back to garoppolo though yes you know i
i look at it from this perspective if he
was a free agent right now yeah
where would he fit in the hierarchy of
the other guys who are going to be
available like how attractive would he
be if he were
free and clear like a tom brady like a
phillip rivers like a ryan tannehill
unless tannehill gets tagged uh you know
where where is he on that on that
pecking order of quarterbacks if he is
on the market
well
mike you can't consider him
along with let's say brady rivers breeze
those guys are uh band-aids right those
guys are one or two-year fixes right and
and to me
you have to look at garoppolo if you're
gonna buy garoppolo okay if you're gonna
buy him all right you have to compare
him
basically probably to ryan tannehill and
teddy bridgewater right
um and and and maybe even taste some
hill because taysom hill i think is the
most fascinating player in free agency
even though he is restricted
and when i look at all these guys mike
one thing i say is
give me the advantage of a guy who's
going to hit the ground running with a
championship ready defense although as
chris said you know there was a
championship level defense for 53
minutes right and then they were the
cleveland browns for seven right so i i
mean i look at this i understand what
you're saying mike but i think there are
so many other things to it than just
simply saying if you plug tom brady into
this team next year you have a better
chance of winning the super bowl than if
jimmy garoppolo plays i'm not even sure
that's true yeah because a 43 year old
quarterback's a 43 year old quarterback
right i i i that's what i would say too
you're exactly right like brees and
brady are good guys you know i'm there
but you've heard me mike i mean i
they're the middle of the pack right now
and that's not to be like disrespectful
to legends i understand that i
understand brady's the goat he's the man
but like peter said he's going to be 43.
he's just he's he's not one of the five
or 10 best quarterbacks in football
anymore and you know to the other
question mike you said like where would
he you know stack up in the pecking
order you know you know that's a good
question i you know do i think i don't
think he's just dak press got a course
i'm gonna give i'm gonna take him over
jimmy garoppolo 100
i'm probably going to take ryan
tannehill over him i think ryan
tannehill probably has more talent than
jimmy garoppolo it's close but i think i
would take tennehill and then there
comes jimmy garoppolo to me in that
conversation then he would be that next
guy in the pecking order um and again
you know i just i think the way this
team's built and the way shanahan
designs offensive plays and things like
that that he'll get better garoppolo and
i just think that this team is not going
anywhere anytime soon because there's
just so much young talent and i don't
know if you'd want to upset that right
now
let me try a different approach yes
a different idea okay chris yes chris
you've told this story before right kyle
and kyle shanahan told it himself last
week patrick mahomes they had the third
overall pick yeah in the
2017 draft they did not take patrick
mahomes because shanahan didn't evaluate
patrick mahomes and why didn't he
evaluate patrick mahomes because he
thought he was gonna get kirk cousins
that's right yes he thought he thought
for sure he was gonna get him go ahead
okay so kirk cousins knows the offense
don't need to bring mike in to teach
kirk cousins the offense right right
kirk cousins is under contract with
minnesota for one more year now look if
he doesn't make that throw to adam
thielen at the end of the playoff win
over the saints maybe this is a a more
plausible conversation right but
the vikings have him under contract for
one more year at 29 and a half million
we don't know what they'd be willing to
do and he has a no trade clause i think
he would waive it if he had a chance to
go be the quarterback of the 49ers
here's the question here's the question
garoppolo is due to make 25.2 million
15.7 million of it is fully guaranteed
as of april 1.
and kirk cousins due to make 29.5
million this year fully guaranteed if
you're john lynch
do you make remember the call he made to
bill belichick in the 2017 season do you
make that call to rick spielman the gm
of the vikings just to see
what it would take to get kirk cousins
you know why i wouldn't make the phone
call let me let me say why i wouldn't
make the phone call
because it's going to get out yes it is
it's going to destroy your team in the
locker room
it's going to destroy
any confidence
that can you imagine how shattered
jimmy garoppolo would be
if he found out that you were trying to
trade for kirk cousins he's already in
the back of his mind he knows this story
in the back of his mind he already knows
that kyle shanahan
wanted kirk cousins right okay so how do
you think he would feel
i mean that would be
a disastrous move there's no way i don't
assume it gets out i'll do that i trust
rick
get out i trust rick spielman to be
discreet about it all right yeah that's
getting out right here yes what's what's
your thoughts well i you know like i i
in theory like
i know what you're saying and i think
kirk cousins is better than jimmy
garoppolo i do yes but i think that's a
very delicate situation and the the
point peter made to me is the point
you know yeah maybe you can trust rick
spielman it better just be rick spielman
on the phone you know if there's other
organizational people involved or
anything like that then it gets scary
because somebody does talk you know
whether they talk to you florio or adam
schefter or peter king or whoever more
times than not those type of rumors seem
to get out in the nfl
but isn't there a way to do it and have
plausible deniability isn't there a way
to have a hypothetical conversation
isn't there a way to just dip your toe
in the water without giving spielman or
anyone else with the vikings ammunition
to whisper to schefter or someone else
that they're talking about possibly
trading for kirk cousins i i just i i i
think there's a way to do it if you
really want to do it i guess that's the
question
how do you do you know you know kyle
better than anybody on this show right
and better than most people in the media
right um what is kyle laying in bed at
night over the next couple of weeks
thinking is there a way that i can
upgrade from jimmy g to kirk c well i i
will not deny that i don't think those
those things are going through his brain
i i don't i think kyle will toss and
exhaust all angles with this and like we
were talking about earlier you know i
think you know the analysis and them you
know going back and studying jimmy
garoppolo they'll do that and they'll do
it hard but i think at the end of the
day shanahan's gonna realize man we were
close
you know this guy i know can get better
i know that and we were up 20 to 10 with
six and a half minutes left in the super
bowl and i think he's gonna just con i
think his his you know his smarts the
realistic reality of the situation
whatever it may be
uh i think he'll just stay status quo
with jimmy g
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports